Pilots come to me if they have stressful situations in the air
or they want to be more focused, and then they come to me and
then we try to solve the problems.
I think it, it was fascinating to me when I, I don't know how I
got exposed to your website, but somehow the name captivated my
imagination very well. Because the name says win
mental, yes. Would you, would you like to
elaborate a little bit on that? Like what does Win mental mean?
I mean, I believe it's a German site, but for English speaking
audiences, how do they make? That.
Yeah, win is winning and mental is mental perspectives,
psychologist perspectives. And so it was a combination from
win, mental, win with mental strength.
But for now, I'm not happy with mental strength, mental things.
I think it's better for paragliders to be flexible
flexibly with your mental sides and not with mental strength.
Because mental strength is, yeah, it's very on one point,
but it's necessary to be open and to be flexible with the
situations, yeah. For sure.
And I think that that kind of transcends in other aspects of
life as well, where where you know a lot is within your
control, but a lot is like outside your your scope of
influence and being flexible or kind of setting your
expectations accordingly is the way to avoid disappointment in
some way. But like what what I'm curious
is that we do have the technical side of sport, which is being
dived into and explained very well.
And then we do have educational side of the sport, which we
impart while bringing in the new pilots in the game and kind of
showing them how it's done. But almost nobody at no stage in
their career talks about the mental side of things.
So from your eyes as a sports psychologist, how does how does
that look and how would you define that side of how do you
put the importance on on that aspect?
Yeah, you say that if we train a lot in the school, we train a
lot with our power glider. But if the health is not
working, then you can not do the, the, the skills you have.
And therefore the mental side is, I think, very important,
especially for beginners, but also for for competition pilots,
because if you stand on the take off and there are a lot of
people when you are nervous, then you do a lot of mistakes.
And so beginners can use mental training to improve.
Yeah, to be relaxed and to be calm and to be focused on what
is to do for now. And this whenever people are
here or the conditions are not very good.
And so it's very important I think.
And also in the air, if you have fly in the terminal and then the
terminal is not very smoothly, it is a little bit bumpy, then a
lot of beginners have problems with the terminal because yes,
they have fear and they have anxiety in the air.
And so you need, I think a way to handle this emotions and with
your thoughts. And of course for competition
pilots also. If you hear pilots, if they are
very good for a long time, then they said, yeah, paracliding
flying depends also from the head and everyone is flying, but
less people. But I think there's a very good
pilots train also the mind as a mental state.
If you hear, yeah, I don't know, Creedle Mauler was and I
interviewed Creedle Mauler and he said he's a good dreamer and
he trained with in the night a lot of strategies, how to fly
ancestors, mental training, if you dream, if you visualize your
strategies or your processes. Yeah, I think that resonates a
lot with visualization. And maybe in modern day
terminology, it can be called as manifestation, which is a new
age word being thrown around where you kind of dream and they
eventually like if you dream long enough, they become your
reality, right? So.
No. OK, please educate.
Me. What did I?
Where did I miss? Sorry, but if you visualize your
your goals and you think OK, this is my goal and I will
visualize this one time 2 * 3 * 5 time, Many people think then
it will be they will achieve his goals, his goals.
But in reality, the scientist shows that if you only visualize
your goals, then our rewarding system in the in the brain is
activated and our brain, our yeah, our mind means OK, we
reached or we also we have already reached the goal and we
have nothing. It's not necessary to do
something. Therefore it's more important,
of course to visualise the goal, but also to visualise the
obstacles, to say, OK, what are the obstacles on the way and
what can I do, which plans I have, this strategies I have to
solve the problems, to solve the obstacles, and what can I do to
yeah, to come, come closer to the goal.
And this is most important, not only visualisations.
The goals? Or is this the obstacles?
I completely agree. Maybe I did not elaborate
myself, but like a realistic visualization where you're not
just dreaming about the podium, but you're dreaming about the
take off, the flight, the hard work, the landings, the decision
making, all the technical things, and then the podium.
So yeah, like take the whole process and not just the cherry
on top basically. Yeah.
Makes sense. You want, let's, let's talk a
little bit about a beginner perspective.
I'm very curious about it because when I was going to do
my course, I mean, first of all, the thing was I was fascinated
with flying even before I got into paragliding.
And I did not get into paragliding for the sake of
paragliding. I got into it because I loved
being in the air one way or the other.
Like even in a commercial flight, you know, I keep on like
I'm one of those guys who books a window seat no matter how long
the flight is. And I'm happy just staring out
and getting fascinated by how the world looks from above.
My beginners course, I couldn't wait to get started and I used
to dream about from whatever references I had.
Of course, YouTube was there, which showed me the point of
view that pilots see and otherwise a little bit that, you
know, imagination of how the birds would fly or something
like that. But let's say my preparation was
satisfactory enough that when I got in the air for the first
time, I was brimming with joy. I was shouting and excitement
and stuff like that. Whereas this process is a bit
different for a lot of other people where they have to
overcome their nerves. And you know, there are like a
lot of other emotions that kind of come with such huge amount of
stimulus that comes into you when you fly for the first time
in a, in a harness and a string and the glider.
So how do you prepare yourself for the very first flight that
you are going to take or one of the first flights?
You know, I mean, like I'm sure there are pilots who are been
there, done that kind of a thing.
So how does early stages of visualization look like from
your point of view? Yeah, I think the first stage is
to see the teacher, to see the teacher how it how he is handles
the flight and the take off. And then you have instruction
and so you train it of course at the training hill.
And then if you first flight then you can realise that you
are nervous, you are on the take off and it's may be steep and
higher than the training hill. And then you recognise this odds
and your emotions. And then it's important to
connect with the service to now this, yeah, this my body and
this what is here and to take off.
And so it's, I think the best way is to breathe two or three
or five things. So breathe deep in and out maybe
two or three or five times. And then you are connected with
your body and with your body. You are in the now, in the not
in the future or in the past what will come, but you are in
the now. And then it's important to
connect what is to do and then you visualize how is the process
of the take off, what is to do, what is the next step and then
have a commitment to do it. And then, OK, I have the trust
from the training here that I do it and now I do it.
It's the first time. It's normal is that you feel
anxiety or you are nervous because it's not sure that it
works. It's your first time but you are
prepared from the training hill and you know in your mind how is
to do and then realize against the process in your mind and
then connect with with your body do it.
The breeding part is very important and I want to come to
that, but I just for the perspective of our listeners who
are racing and competing in in the World Cups, let's try and
put ourselves in their shoes. They have to go out and fly a
task basically they have to think about the day, visualize
their road to take off on the take off, clipping in, strapping
on like inflation of the glider, you know, be it reverse or
forward, depending upon how are the take off looks.
Then circling in the Google, you know, reaching the top and then
the first glide and then the next trigger point and then the
final glide is is, is that like basically you kind of look
forward to what are the possibilities, play them in your
head and then be ready for execution when the time
eventually comes. Yes you can do plans, you can
different situations. You can the start gaggle with
your lies. OK what is to do in the start
gaggle? You have to do circle with the
other ones and come up and be the highest to take off the
start time supposed to be the best and then OK the first
client and then circling again and how to push and how to
circle with the other pilots. And yeah, since you can
visualize and if you have distractors like thoughts or
emotions during the flight, what's what is to do if you have
sister structures from outside, maybe the mobile phone is
ringing or something else. And what is to do if this comes?
This is this, Yeah. And then you have a plan and
this plan you can also visualize.
OK, I hear it. And then I breathe in the air.
OK, do the mobile phone out and focus on the next waypoint or
the next climbing. And yeah, do it.
But the most as if you have distractors from the outside
like a mobile phone, it's important to preparate it in
front of the flight just as well.
Switch off the sounds, the ring sound maybe, Yeah.
And from the inner side, thoughts and emotions, they can
come. And this is not so light to
switch off. It's difficult.
And for such situations, it's in my opinion good to accept them
because it's not possible to yet to switch off their thoughts.
But you can switch off the struggle with the thoughts and
the with the feelings. You can accept, OK, here is the
thought of whatever and I have the feeling of fear or whatever.
I am a little bit nervous, OK, I feel this.
I have the thoughts and then OK, I breathe in, breathe out,
connect with my body, OK. And what is now to do to do is
focus on the next term, auto cycling with the other pilots.
So you said that it's not possible to switch off the
thoughts, but it's possible to switch off the struggle with the
thoughts. Let's elaborate a little bit
upon that. Because thoughts are just a
natural part of your daily existence and they can't be
switched on and off within a day.
Like it takes a process. It takes a specified way of life
which you develop over a period of time, like habits and stuff
like that, where your thoughts become in a certain pattern and
then they just don't come that spontaneously or that
aggressively. But when it comes to the
struggle of thoughts, I'm a bit confused.
Like how do you switch off the struggle with the thoughts?
Breathing of course is a way to oxygenate yourself more and but
I'm hitting a roadblock here. Could you please explain this
topic? Yeah, if you have thoughts as
it's not possible to stop your flow of thoughts come and
sounds, sounds, thoughts goes and maybe the change in your
head and you have a big choice of thoughts in your head.
Some thoughts are helpful, some thoughts are not so helpful and
but there are thoughts. And if you have a thought that
is not so helpful, then it could be that you are struggling.
So you say, OK, I don't want to have the thought, it's not
helpful. I want to stop this, I want to
avoid the thoughts. And if you do this, my
experiences and the signs say the same, that you try to avoid
thoughts and feelings, then the thoughts and feelings will
become bigger and have more power.
This is not very helpful. I tried it in the past and the
beginning of my mental training time.
I say to pilots OK if you have not had for the thoughts do stop
sign say in your in a loud stop and then change it to a positive
thing. And this is also not possible
for light thoughts not so more not so important thoughts as
possible. But if the thoughts are anxiety,
if you have fearful thoughts, then it's not possible to to
change it in a positive way. Then you have devil and until on
your shoulder and the one says, OK, I can't do it.
I'm a good pilot. And the devil said says, oh,
there is a look. There is a paraglider is have a
collapse and you are not able to handle the and say and she says,
OK, you want you are a good pilot, you have train it and you
can't do it. And the devil says, Oh no, it's
a very turbulent day-to-day and you are not able to handle it.
And though you have a discussion in you and this is strangling
struggle with the sorts and to try to avoid it or to try to
bring it back. And this has cost a lot of
energy and this energy you need to fly to in flight to, to take
good decisions. But if you use the energy for
this discussion or to avoid the thoughts, you lose a lot of
mental energy. And it could and you are not
focused on the flight. And so you can stop struggling
with the thoughts and accept, OK, here are the thoughts.
The thoughts I have it OK, maybe it's helpful or not, but it's
the thoughts or I connect with my body, make a deep breath in,
out and then I show make a reality check.
Maybe fearful thoughts maybe have a good reason.
Maybe the weather is changing also.
Then I can say, OK, the thought are right.
The weather is changing, the flying conditions are not really
safe for now it's good. Then I can say, OK, thank you
brains that you give me the thoughts.
It's a good decision to go landing.
Then it's good, but sometimes the thoughts are not helpful.
It's also it's just in my head, but it's not the reality.
Then I say, OK, it's a terminal day, it's a little bit bumpy,
but it's not dangerous to fly further.
It's just in my head that I have thought, OK, then I breathe in,
breathe out, connect with my goal.
My goal is in the competition, fly to the goal.
OK, I fly further and the conditions are safe and I flew
further and the thoughts can be fly with me or not, but I focus
on the next terminal. I focus on the way on my route
on the next Turnpike. But I don't use energy for
fighting against my thoughts and feelings.
It's OK if that the feelings are here.
It's maybe I don't like it maybe, but it's OK that they are
here and I focus on what is necessary to do.
And this is focus on the next terminal, on the next turn
point, the next. Step.
Yeah. So basically to sum it up is
accept your state of mind and focus on the task on hand
because that is the only thing that will get you out of it.
Yeah. Makes sense because otherwise
it's a. Yeah, it's the most important
thing to be focused, to stay focused, to realise, OK, I have
it, I have the thoughts, and then to diffuse from the
thoughts and connect with the thing, to do what is, to do what
I have to. I'm very curious about the power
of breathing. You know, I've, I've heard the
miracles of deep breathing over and over at different times,
different point and times in my life.
What happens when you take a deep breath?
What is the science behind it, and how does it make clarity
become a mainstream from all the fog that you're dealing with
that that time? As a priest have a lot of
impacts. The first impact is that you
come from your head and your body, and so you switch with
your focus from your head and the body.
This is the first thing. The second thing is if you make
a deep breeze in your, what is this here diaphragm, stomach in
your stomach? Yeah, if you make a deep breeze
in your stomach, then you activate your Patterson
particles and this is the player against the stress reaction.
So you calm down, you relax, the body relax.
And if you calm down, if you are in a stress reaction, then your
brain, your rational part of your brain's cortical cortex is
not working very good because it's necessary to survive in a
dangerous situation. And to the rational part, who
decides, OK, which is the best decision now is not necessary
for the for the survival in a really dangerous situation.
And therefore it works not very good.
But if you calm down with the deep breathe, then you gain time
and the body relax. And then your brain can also
work again and then you can make good decisions.
But the other side and this breathe, it depends on the way
you breathe. If you breathe deep, then you
can relax. If you breathe in and for a
longer time outs and it's also for relaxing.
And if you breathe in in a very fast time and in a very fast
out, then it can also activate you.
So if you as your body isn't survey you breathe, have
influence of your feeling. And yeah.
Makes sense I want to talk a little bit about the power of
warming up before entering activity I come from a
conventional sports background where I played hockey on a
fairly high level land hockey not ice.
But the thing that I learned during those times was that warm
up has incredible power to shape your gameplay time because it is
basically that you're preparing yourself for what's coming.
You're talking to your body, your body is talking back to
you. You're sending signals to your
brain. You're kind of getting ready for
the action ahead in a cross country flight.
That was the one of the biggest surprise to me that you just get
out of a car or a cable, like whatever it is.
Like if it's a hiking flight, it's a different thing that you
are still a bit active and you've kind of thought about it
on the way. But most takeoffs when you take
motorized form of transport on the way, you just get out there,
you chill on the takeoff for a bit and then you jump into the
harness and then you're like playing the game basically.
Like let's say air is the field of play.
So you enter the field of prey play right from the dressing
room. There is no warm up field in
between. This was very surprising to me
because I have always been told that there is a buffer between
the dressing room and the field of play.
That is the warm up pitch where the you prepare yourself for
whatever is coming and you set the tone for it.
In World Cups it's a little bit different because before the
start time goes, you are above the start gate and you're
circling for a little bit. So it is not the most optimal,
but it still gives you a bit of a headway.
What I've been thinking is that since breathing has so much
power and of course meditation and focus and everything is like
so in tune with it, would it not make sense for our sport to have
a 1520 minute warm up session which consists of breathing or
yoga or some form of meditation or or everything included where
you go to the take off? And I'm not saying that you go
out and run and stretch. I mean OK stretching helps.
I have tried warming up my body as well before going out on the
on the World Cup goggles or something like that where I'm
like I want to be sure if a collapse comes I won't be sure
that my muscles are warmed up and ready to act quickly.
But how would ideal warm up session look like, which might
consist of yoga, meditation and breathing exercises according to
you? Yeah, I think it's the
individual thing, but you are right the warm up have also the
function of OK I have a ritual and sys ritual brings me to the
spot and sys ritual is also helpful for paragliders.
And I'm recommend to to make own ritual because, yeah, I think
the most important thing is 6 are the conditions quote yes, as
the conditions good for flying or not?
Or could it a little bit could there Yeah, difficult whatever.
And therefore it's good maybe to come at the take off and take 5
minutes or 10 minutes to yeah, to see the vessels conditions.
And then it would be also good to focus on yourself to set, OK,
what is my goal today? What will I achieve today?
Is it excel flight? Is it acro manoeuvre?
Is it a competition or what is the goal?
And OK, it's good to feel also the mental and the physical
situations. And I'm fit meant from my body
and from my psychology side. Have I stress or what is the
problems or have I no problems? I'm really fit to fly.
And meditation would be a great thing if you take 10 minutes
maybe from the take off to sit down and to please and to
connect with my goals and current situation in
competitions. You say, OK, in World Cup some
pilots have a return, some pilots have headphones and hear
music. And this is also to come in the
optimal zone of function to because if you are too bored
then you have not the optimal function and you are not in the
good shape to handle good in the air.
And if you are on the other side, you are have fear and you
are very stressful, then you're also not in the optimal or
function. So it's necessary to have the
balance and so you it's necessary to feel OK.
Are I am too relaxed or are I'm too feel too stressful?
And what can I do to come in the optimal area of function?
And if you are too nervous then it's good maybe to make a deep
breath brace or to change your body posture.
If you have a big powerful body posture then you'll feel more
confidence and can handle better instead of you have a small body
posture. Or if you have, if you are too
bored, too calm, then you are also not in the optimal area,
then you have to activate you and therefore it makes sense to
take time before you start to to feel how is my mental and my
physical shape the moment and then to do something to came in
the optimal area. Yes, I think of warm up to be
good. Some pilots make ground handling
in the front of the take off, but it's not really good if the
take off is full of Yeah as a. Violent.
Yeah. Then it's.
Not to recommend, but it's also a wave to to warm up.
And in the competitions you say, OK, you fly and then you have
the time from take off to the start time.
And in this time you can warm up a little bit and you can feel
how is the air today. And this is a way of warm up and
says can you also do an an XF fly?
I fly out and surf try OK how do I feel today and how is the air
today and then go to my XF flight start to my XF.
Yeah, like just don't jump into the flight right away, you know,
take your own time and assessing and talking to your body, mind,
glider everything, muscles, you know, all around it you want to
like. OK, very short quick tip on
breathing. Let's say, what is the simplest
breathing technique that pilots can apply at any given point in
time and flight to help them get more mental clarity?
Focus on your breathe and breathe in and out is nothing to
do or is the focus on your breathe look OK?
How breathe in and how preside out and feel how the Prius is on
your nose and in your lungs and maybe on your shoulder.
Where can you feel the priest? It's the simple thing.
Just focus on your priest. That is one of the simplest
forms of meditation as well because I, I've been to 1 of
this Buddhist monk meditation workshops and they said that one
of the easiest way to get your thoughts together is to just
close your eyes and either listen to the sounds that the
nature is giving you. I mean, if it is natural or man
made, it doesn't matter. But the other one is to focus on
your breathing, which resonates to what you just said.
Unless you're super close to the Cliff and you have to kind of
make better decisions at that time.
So then prioritize your reality more than you know mindfulness
at that time. But talking about poses you
want, I wanted to talk about the importance of posing.
Of course, your posture you said, reflects a lot.
Do you know about this thing called power pose?
Power pose is basically a position in a body where you
stand with your hands on hips. Of course, that one is as well
where you, where you raise your hands, That is a different one
as well. But the other one is where you,
you know, there's a very famous Wonder Woman character which is
standing on the hips, having hands on hips and with that.
So I, I'm not sure how scientifically true this is, but
I heard that doing power pose for up to a certain time
increases your testosterone or concentration up to a certain
percentage. And I did not know this.
I had no idea that this used to be done.
But then I realized after I, after I read this that I have
been subconsciously doing this at every single take off before
going on to the flight. So what is the science behind
these kind of poses that make us feel a lot more confident from
our current baseline? And we gained 1520% extra for no
reason. The person I don't know but Amy
Caddy Caddy. Amy Caddy is a psychologist from
America and she makes a lot of studies about body postures.
And this one, she make a study of this, this hands up and the
feet like U.S. star. You stand there like a star and
you look to the to our path and you are smiling.
Yeah. So it's a very powerful post.
And if you do this for 5 minutes and then you go to the to a very
important meeting, then you are more able to be how you are
naturally be. And you can, I don't know in
English. You're more confident.
So you, yeah, you are more confident and you can say what
you want to say and you feel better.
And also CIS poacho is also. Hands on hips.
Yeah, all powerful poses. You make your big and your stand
very. Solid.
Solid on the ground then you feel good and it's had also on
your head influence on your feelings.
And if you make you a little bit smaller, women's tend to be
makes them smaller than men. Men have bigger postures than
women. And if you make your small and
not powerful potions then you are more depressive and you have
a bad feelings and you feel not so confident.
Instead of I have a big poster powerful posture posture.
So what can let's say to all the women pilots listing out there,
What can they do to not be in their usual small state?
Because I think, I don't know if it's instinctive or natural or
something, but they tend to do it more often than men.
So what is their way? Or if there's any man who
doesn't go out and make himself bigger, like, how do you
challenge that notion and come out of it?
Yeah, keep attention on your body posture and if you see that
your shoulders go down and your head goes down, then make an
other posture, change it, make it big.
Do your hands here or not much better do this.
But maybe it looks a little bit strange if you stand on takeoff
and makes, but maybe you can do it on the toilet or in the wood
or wherever and then make a big poster and hold it for 5 or 10
minutes and then you will feel that poster will influence you
in your mind. And with my clients, I try to
find a motto goal and a motto goal has the poster inside.
And what to go from me is I go further like elephant in the in
the and if I see it in my inner eye, an elephant, then I'm
naturally go in a big post body posture that's very good.
So I have an elephant also here on my wall and on my desk and me
OK, I'm an elephant and go further.
I like an elephant and go further.
And if I think on the elephant, so my body posture is actually
naturally because then I think not on this fascinating.
So it yeah. So it's good to find goals in
what I want to do and this inner feeling I want to have.
And then it's good to find a picture that's represent
represent this image that helps to find naturally the right
posture. A quick question comes to my
mind. You want Paragliding is more or
less a solo sport. Once you're in the air, you're
by yourself. There's nobody making those
decisions or reaping the rewards for work, for your actions.
But let's say it's still a social sword on the way to the
take off, at the landing, on the take off, before you get in the
air. How do you handle conflicts with
other pilots in these situations?
Because it could be a group of pilots, they could have their
own priorities. Some of them are good friends
with you, some of them are not so good friends with you.
There could be healthy rivalries, animosities, you
know, just banter. So when it comes to dealing with
friction with other pilots, what is the usual go to thing that a
pilot themselves can do to try and avoid themselves from those
kind of energies? Friction.
You OK? You mind the conflicts?
They have other goals like me or 6.
Could be anything as I said, you know, like they, they could have
their own friend circle which you're not a part of or they
could have their own kind of XC group which does better than you
or anything like you know, anything which is not meeting
your expectations as a social animal and you are not a part of
that tribe at that time. OK, I'm the first thing is to
recognize this, this behaviour. Then I can go to the pilots and
if this is a problem, OK, the pilots land, not land on the
landing field, but go not to the place to where normally you have
to pack in the clouder. Then I have go to them and say,
OK, I see you pack the clouder here, but not on the right
place, no problem because we have problems with the farmers
here. Please go to the right place and
yeah, send maybe the pilot do it or not.
If not, then I say, OK, I told you it's important that you go
to this place, but you don't do it.
But that's the reason. Please tell me why do you not
hold on the rules and if you have the problem with you said,
OK, I want to I want a big flight and I don't reach it, but
as a pilots do it. So it was part of your question
then it's important. OK, what was my goal?
And if I remember on the beginning at my XT flights, I
have in the XT contest some pilots where I from which I sort
of they are on my level. And so there I look how far they
will fly if I've if on my flying days.
And then I had a really good flight for me and I achieve a
goal, a big Tiger on a big values champ that I didn't
achieved before and I was very happy about after the flight.
And then I go to the exit contest, I load up my flight and
then I see as a pilot on my watching list flew 10 kilometers
further. And so I feel shit, yes, and
such a stupid because I achieve a goal, a very big goal.
I did this very champ. And so the my recommendation now
is focus on your goals, focus on your flights.
And if you achieve your process goals, process goals, then it's
good. And it's not important if some
people fly 10 kilometers more or some people is in the
competition in front of you on or not.
It's important that you reach achieve your process goal, your
chemist. And so it's a reason to be happy
to achieve your next step. So you're basically saying that
FOMO is like FOMO has to be taken out of the equation, and
the only way to do that is to be content with what you
accomplished because somehow to me, like FOMO exists to
everyone. Yes, for my for everyone, and
maybe you have the thoughts like I'm frustrating because I didn't
are so good like the other one or whatever.
Or I'm missing this good flight because I have to work and other
pilots were flying today because the conditions were very good
and I have to But then it's the same thoughts in the air.
Accept that the emotions and thoughts are because it's
naturally that this thoughts can come and send.
Do the same like in the air, make a deep breathe and then
connect. With the.
Present moment crowning yourself and come to your body and then
clarify your values. What is important is to come a
step further. I go further like an.
Elephant in the step. Clarify your values and then do
what is the next step. And also important is to be as
friendly with yourself. Kindly with yourself recognise
that this feelings are common and a part of our human life.
It's normal and it's not necessary to to fight against
ourselves, but are kind full. And.
Accepts that this thoughts can come, but connect with your
values and your goals. What is important for you in
paragliding? Yeah, try and look at the
positives and the task on hand. And not be to develop on
whatever has happened and is behind it's behind for a reason.
Basically I'm very curious you want, I don't know if you can
answer this or not, but did you interview Kregel after the
exalts or before the exalts? Not after the last exiles.
No, it was, I think one or two years before.
Yeah, after the last excerpts, I didn't interview.
I was like wondering how does a person?
Like him, who has seen his reality take him to a legendary
status, navigate missing out on a podium because obviously you
know, he has he has a certain set of discipline which kind of
trains which allows him to handle his emotions.
But then suddenly having such a huge challenge in front of your
life where you're not on the podium, like what would be or if
you can kind of elaborate on that, like, what would be the
ideal steps to be taken? Yeah, when something that big
happens. Yeah, I think.
Creedal will. Not.
Have a bit, a big struggle with the situations, I think.
I'm not sure. I think because in my interview
he said. I asked him, OK, you've won so
many times, it motivates you to be a part of the excerpts again,
because he can lose. He can, Yeah, he cannot.
But his reputation is at stake every time, yes.
But he said to. Me and that is the most
important part, he said to me he want to be perfect and he finds
all the time some parts of his process which are not perfect.
And his goal is to be perfect to to be to do perfect process and
the whole competition. And I think this is exactly what
I say. It's important to clarify what
is what are my values for what want I to stay?
For me, it's important to be connected with the nature.
For me, it's important to have fun, to be connected with other
people, to have a team and send concentrate the sys values and
focus on sys values and do the next step.
And I think Kriegel will also concentrate on the next step.
OK, Some things were not so good at the last excise maybe.
And so you've been changed those parts.
And I think he will try it again at the next time and focus on
the next step. OK, what can I do?
And result is out of our control zone, out of our zone of control
because we cannot control the result, we cannot say we are
first or 10 or 100 in the competition.
But what we can control is our mind, our as well our mind in
the sense of OK, I keep focused, I accept my thoughts, I'm
connect with the present moment. I connect with my values and my
goals and I do what is necessary to do, set us what I can connect
control, but I cannot control the result.
And I think this is important. And also if you don't achieve
your goal if you. Achieve your process.
Goals and you are connected with your values and it's a big
success. OK, I have a.
Question this is. Something that I've struggled
with myself, a lot of us. Know this I'm pretty sure like.
50% or probably more listeners who are tuning in to us right
now are aware of these things, that they exist and that's how
you do them. But why are such tasks easier
said than done? Because having knowledge about
them is one thing, but like, putting them into action is a
whole different thing. Yeah, it's raining.
To now it's easy. You say it, it's.
Easy to know this, but to be to stay in the present moment, it's
very difficult. Yeah.
But if you meditate in the first time, maybe you try to count
your breezes and before you reach 10 breezes, your thoughts
are. It's whatever.
Yeah, it's. Totally normal.
And it's training. If you do it often, if you do it
the tenth times or say 100 times, that it's easier.
And I think the most important thing is to know it and tend to
do it. And if you do it often and you
do it 12345 times, then it will be easier.
And then it's easier to stay in the present moment.
And I'm also, I train for a lot of time, a long time.
And of course my mind is sometimes also distracted from
whatever. And the important thing is to
recognise, OK, my mind is far from my flight, and then come
back to the flight and connect you with the present moment and
do it again and again and with the time.
It's easier. Yeah.
But thank you for your honesty. Yeah.
It's not so easy. I'm I.
Know it. Because yeah, I think it deep
down. It comes down to discipline.
And like, how much of you of it do you want to have in your
life? And discipline doesn't come
easy. That's a lot of hard work,
building habits, patterns and saying no to dopamine hits.
But yeah, we're talking about. Sorry.
Go on. Yeah, Yonka, but since 8:00.
OK, if you do his course, he has the course manual for mind phone
and base stress reduction. And in this course, if you do
it, you have the duty to meditate one hour per day for
eight at least. And it's a lot, yes.
But in his, in his opinion, it's if you meditate one hour per day
for eight weeks for the during the course, then then it's, then
it's, but find the actual that you do it again after this time.
It needs a little bit discipline to do it.
But I think it's not necessary to meditate one hour per day.
But if you start with 5 minutes per day or 10 minutes per day,
it's enough. And it's important to come to a
mindfulness and a more mindfulness life, more mind from
his flight and recognize, OK, I'm not mindful, and then come
back and focus on what is to do. I think the 8.
Week time period is. Given based on the 40 day habit
formation, you know, timeline, because that is a common thing,
then a lot of people say that if you want to form a habit, do it
for 40 days and it becomes I think but talking about, you
know, we were talking about dopamine rush and hits at that
time beforehand. But like social media is a huge
thing and doom scrolling or the ill effects of it are becoming
more and more common. I mean, OK, this might not be
that relevant for pilots who are above the age of 4045 because by
that time you're kind of like some are reaching a point where
they're not scrolling as much. But for anybody who is spending
more than 15 minutes, or I mean, the, the upper limits are pretty
mad. Like people are spending 910
hours scrolling sometimes as well.
How does scrolling make you a bad flyer?
Because I'm going to put it out that simply like comparison is
the root of all evil. And if Instagram is showing you
a super cool flight location, flight being done in a super
cool location, or somebody you know, smashing his actual tricks
or somebody flying in a guy, well, you're going to end up
comparing by default. So that's why I want to
simplify. This question that how?
Does scrolling make your flying bad?
Yeah, 1. Thing is FOMO.
Pair with. Other pilots and.
See, OK, other pilots are already flying and I'm working
and that makes you frustrating and maybe more stressful because
as a pilot, to start with, you paracliding and OK, they make
more progress than you and so you feel also bad.
And if you feel bad and frustrated, maybe, yeah, the
paradox thing is maybe you're trained less, and if you're
trained less than you will not. Make good progresses.
And also you are distracted, this is scrolling also YouTube
or whatever. And you're distract from your
goals and from your values. And it's important that your
focus on your goals and values and your own progress and not
what other people are doing. And there are studies that's too
much social media time have never negative effects on mental
health for depression. Yeah.
And so on. You know, I, I want to.
Clarify for some people who might be having the notion that
social media helps up to an extent.
Because a lot of times I get this, I get this message that
no, I only look at good accounts.
I only look at people who teach something, but for me, when was
the last time you learnt how to handle an asymmetric from an
Instagram reels that you can remember in an SIV, learning
does not happen in 15 second scrolls.
And to me the learning, the best form of learning is writing it
down or you know, doing things on hands because that is
practicality. In fact, even typing is very
different because back in the day when we used to write
everything with our own hands with a pencil and a paper or
like on a pen and a paper, it used to register in your heads
much more than what it does today.
Let's talk about learning from scrolling.
Is it really effective up to an extent, or is this just a joke
that is being thrown around so people can still stay addicted?
Yeah. It depends.
If you use no but like to me. It does not.
To me it is. It is nothing but a fake.
You know if you use. Scrolling for distraction, for
handle stress, maybe to relax then it's avoidance strategy and
it's not really helpful if maybe you see I don't know.
I think the best I'm with. You I think it's better to do it
in reality to go to the trainer and see what is to do.
Maybe if you want to learn a full start, it's better to go in
the SIV and become become the to get the instruction and then
write it down the process like you toilet yeah pen and paper
yeah yeah, with the pen and. Paper.
And then go mental through the process and then do it.
This is the best way of learning.
But yeah, I don't know. As is the most.
Dangerous thing of social media I think is the FOMO because you
compare with other people and see OK they have a better life
than me and this is frustrating and makes your depression.
No, no, that is one thing for sure, that.
A lot of people are agreeing on, but a lot of times when I ask
people that why can't you give up scrolling, they're like, no,
we try to look at the good side of social media where we are
learning some things off it. And to me, when you're getting
that huge of a dopamine rush, the learning takes a backstage
and entertainment takes a first stage.
And you know, but a thought just came to my mind that I would
like to share is imagine watching something with full
immersion and trying to learn it.
And then imagine watching like this could be live, you know,
for example, there's somebody demonstrating how to make a rope
knot in front of you. Like there are endless amount of
rope knot types and somebody's teaching you how to make the
knots with a rope. And then imagine doing the same
process with a cigarette and a bottle of beer in your hand.
Because alcohol and tobacco are going to give you dopamine,
right? So imagine learning the process
of tying a rope without having these distractions, and then
imagine repeating the whole things with these distractions
because dopamine is more or less entertaining.
It's not like I don't know, I'm not, I'm not into science.
But to me, dopamine is meant for entertainment.
And then learning is a very different cognitive ability of
the brain, which is not getting prioritized when you're getting
the rush from a whole different stimuli.
So yes, you might learn that asymmetric or that full stall
for like those 10 seconds, but within that like short term
memory loss is going to hit you so damn quickly that within the
next scroll, when you see something going on in other side
of the world or something in the street or some people fighting
in a in a train or you know, a scam going around or like 2
animals having a cute laugh, that full stall video is gone.
Like your brain is not registering that asymmetric or
that full stall that you saw. But somehow you've convinced
yourself that I am opening Instagram to watch and learn
more things about paragliding. But in in reality, you hear
scrolling because that alcohol and cigarette defect is so damn
addictive that you just can't let go of it at every evening
before going to the bed, more or less Yeah, what you described is
the. Reason.
Because people, humans, have shorter time, ability to focus
on one. Yeah, the attention spans are
reducing. And surface mindful training.
Very important because this mindful training to do one thing
one thing and not. With.
Cigarettes and alcohol and with whatever, just focus on one
thing and it's important to to learn and it's important to to
train our ability for focus and so many things doing on the same
time brings your brain in stress and you are not able to be
aware. I find it very surprising that
we were. Told to get into multitasking to
sharpen our brains, but then eventually, like it has come
back and said that multitasking isn't the way that we are
supposed to function. So it's yeah, it's a hidden
trial. Like you never know until you
try. But yes, enough people have
tried and kind of come to the conclusion that stop
multitasking even though it is just scrolling a finger on the
screen like you can either scrolling, scrolling is also
most. Multitasking 1 Pilot says to me,
if he come at home and in the evening, he scrolled to the
social media accounts and this is for relaxing, but it's not
relaxing. You have a lot of input in a
short time and yeah, the brain is not able to work with this
short experiences is this experience.
It's like somebody saying that I want to go out.
For a cigarette break. And I want to relax.
No. You want to go out to kill your
craving because your body is asking you for something that
you're missing. So you're not getting relaxed.
You feel relaxed after you fulfill the craving, but you
don't understand the want of craving itself is not the
essence of relaxing. Yeah, Yeah, I'm.
So glad we could bring it out like.
Clearly, because these thoughts bounce on and off in my head,
but like doing it with a sports psychologist, it's a whole new
level of enlightenment for me as well.
Yeah, it's a form of. Addiction scrolling in in social
media, of course. Yeah, you want.
Before we kind of. Close for the day.
I want to talk about balancing life and flying to me.
Yeah, this is something, again, which is not spoken about a lot
and nobody tells you. I feel one of the most important
things that new beginner courses are missing, where we bring in
new pilots, is that first you have to tell people the
importance of warming up, which can be indifferent.
You know, there can be a whole different way to do it, as we
spoke about in the beginning of the show.
But the second thing is to tell them how addictive flying is
because it actually has the power to take over your life.
Like you can end up giving every other possession or want in
chasing of airtime. And there are so many of us, me
included. Like I had a very different
lifestyle before I got into flying.
And I mean OK I was fascinated with the air and flying and
everything before getting into paragliding.
But the moment I realized that it is such a simple form of
aviation and the reward is so freaking amazing, I was like,
fuck that shit. Let me just leave that stability
and chase this whatever adrenaline or, you know,
satisfaction that comes from it. So too much of anything is bad.
There's no rocket science to that.
How do you understand that at this point in time, flying is
taking a toxic space in your life, whereas it was supposed to
take it was supposed to be a whole different thing.
And. And in all, it's like, yeah,
yeah, I. Think.
Yeah, I'm with you. Parag lighting is addiction.
I'm also addicted for parag lighting, of course.
That's the reason why I'm that's.
One reason why I'm self-employed, so I have more
flexibility with the weather and so on.
But yeah, then it's a problem. It's a problem is so you have to
clarify what is important in your life.
Paragliding is one part of your life, but you have also family,
you have work, you have friends, maybe you have other hobbies and
so on. And it's, it's necessary to
declare to clarify what is important in my life.
And if the family comes to short because you are paragliding all
the time or if your works come to to short because you are
paragliding all the time, and then it could be difficult or it
could be a problem. And I think it's important to
clarify what is really important in my life and then set
priorities. And if my best friend is my best
friend married in May, it's a good paragliding time.
Me it was clear in May OK, my best friend is a merit on this
day. OK, if the weather.
Is really good. I don't go to fly because.
My friend is more important. Than paragliding at this day and
so it's important to find the balance and parrot lining Of
course it makes a lot of fun and it's a big part of my life but
it's one part of my life I have also other parts also for me
it's important to be present for my clients.
I want to be present for my friends.
I want also time for my boyfriend and yeah, for my
family and so on. And so far it is necessary to
have a balance. Of course, in the summertime
paragliding have a bigger part, but.
On the autumn or in the. Winter time I'm also use the
time for my friends and for my family and so on, but also is
important in my life and of course I am we totally agree
with you. It's should be a lesson in
education to say the pilots paragliding will change your
life. Of course, yes, does to so many
of us. You know, like it's.
It's almost a shame that we, and I think that is the reason why
we lose out a lot of people as well.
We don't retain that much, even though it's like one of the
simplest forms of aviation because there are so many gaps
in the learning, especially in the early stages that you either
have to, you know, I mean, there's a saying called fuck
around and find out because that is like one of the easiest ways
to do it yourself. But the other one is like, yeah,
if you just get lucky or find a mentor or something.
But there's not a lot of structured support system that
does the hand holding until the level of independence.
I'm not saying dependence like that, but I'm not saying like,
you know, there are people who keep you who like to stay on
radio and stuff like that, but they're in in conventional
corporate careers, for example, you are given a structured
schooling up to the high school level and then like the
university kind of gives you a little bit of more mature into
the job market. And then finally you kind of,
you know, get into an apprentice and then you become a
practitioner by yourself. Conventional sports, it's a bit
different where you enter academies and reach up the
levels of the leagues, but here is like, hey, two weeks of a
course and then go out and explore yourself and make all
the decisions either by paying a lot of yeah, yeah, it's the.
Shortest form of becoming a. Pilot in any form of aviation
so. And it's hardly regulated.
It's hardly. Which is like, OK, free flight
is nice, but a new beginner does not know shit about what world
is he entering and we are just telling them how to inflate the
glider and flare properly, not even handle the ring folding
tendencies or whatever it is like that comes much later in
the progression. Yeah, it's also a problem.
If you have. In this two weeks perfect
weather, then you have your license in two weeks and you
flew in perfect weather but after the.
Course you come. In different weather conditions
and maybe you are not able to handle this.
Therefore 2 weeks I decree very short and maybe you are not
enough prepared for the situations.
Yeah, you. Won't before we close.
When a client comes to you or like, you know, for anybody
who's listening, who who wants to reach out and kind of have
your services, what is the way, What do you identify?
What can they look to improve and how does it work?
Yeah. Yeah, it depends from the reason
why the clients come and he will come to me and then I will do a
speech with him and I will clear assessment, I think assessment.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I want to clarify what is the
reason why he want my service And then we make a plan.
How could it works? Often clients come with stress
and anxiety. And then the most important
thing is I think to accept to learn to accept the thoughts and
to learn to diffuse from thoughts and emotions and also
clarify my values and my goals. And since we can do it in a
session and. Yeah.
And then I think one of the most important thing is also
mindfulness, and this must every client do on his own.
I can give some instructions. Then it's training.
You said it. It's very easy to say it and to
know it, but it's very difficult to make it.
And you train online. As well.
Or is most of them done in person?
Most is yeah. Is.
Online less pilots come to me to Fronten.
Fronten is a very small town in the South of Germany and the
most pilots are not in Fronten. And therefore I'm I work a lot
online. Yes, I mean all I can.
Say is that you're 1. Of the first ones offering such
services in our sport. And I really am thankful that
you gave your time to the show to educate people the importance
of such a training. And so yeah, anybody who's
listening to this, you know if you have been wanting to touch
the sky with glory in a better manner, then here is a solution.
We'll link your website to the show notes and probably pilots
can reach out to you and take it from there on.
Yes, thank you. Thank.
You for this meeting, for this session.
You're welcome.